in the city of Newark New Jersey
everyone is feeling the heat and
humidity
it's extremely hot like I never felt
this hot in this plus I have one gene so
it's hot yes older young they're all
suffering through one of the hottest
days of the year
it's it's real hot out here
I'm saying just you got to keep drinking
the only thing I keep fluids in your
bias real hot it's dry it's a little
it's a little like the heat is like it's
just too dense like
the air it's hard to breathe scientists
call it a heat island it's a place that
retains more heat because of the way
that it's built researchers did a study
and concluded that the place I'm in
right now is one of the most severe heat
islands in the entire United States in
Newark you've got 700 000 people who are
exposed to temperatures that are at
least eight degrees hotter because of
the built environment because of the
neighborhoods in which they lived Newark
is dense lots of concrete few trees or
green spaces all the characteristics of
a heat island
particularly difficult for the elderly
for me it's okay because I I feel like
I'm in good shape but for the elders and
different people that ain't used to the
heat it could be extremely hot we're not
really used to they get hot in in Newark
but it hasn't been this hot in a while
being honest with you when we ask
residents what's causing the high
temperatures they don't hesitate does he
and the way it's going from from coast
to coast they're just telling you
global warming
in a city where many don't know when the
heat might end but do seem to be
confident on what's causing it Gabriel
Elizondo Al Jazeera Newark New Jersey